تم اكتشاف 30 مقبرة جماعية تحتوي على رفات
أكثر من ألف شخص
في غرب دارفور، وفقًا
لمسؤولين محليين في مقابلة حصرية لشبكة CNN، قامت
نعمة الباقر، مراسلة CNN وفريقها، بتجميع مقطع
فيديو آخر من مذبحة وقعت في غرب
دارفور في يونيو، وكانت واحدة من أكثر المذبحة
دموية.  في تاريخ المنطقة،
انتهى الأمر بجثث الضحايا متناثرة في
الشوارع ودُفنت في نهاية المطاف في
المقابر الجماعية، ونريد أن نحذركم من أن
بعض الصور التي نحن على وشك أن نحضرها
لكم في هذا التقرير المهم هي
رسوم بيانية ويتضمن التقرير
أوصافًا مؤلمة.  تم تصوير هذا
الصراع
في خطر كبير من قبل الناجين، ويظهر
الفيديو كتابات عنصرية تشوه
الجدران والجثث المتناثرة في الشوارع، كما
يظهر هنا في دعايتهم الخاصة.
احتلت قوات الدعم السريع شبه العسكرية السودانية مدينة جنينة في يونيو/حزيران
بعد حملة قصف عنيفة
والقتال في حربها من أجل الهيمنة على
كشف تحقيق أجرته شبكة سي إن إن للجيش السوداني الآن عن بعض تكاليف
انتصار قوات الدعم السريع هنا في جنينة. [
تصفيق]
وصف الناجون عمال الإغاثة وجامعو الجثث لشبكة سي إن إن كيف قامت قوات الدعم السريع بالتعاون
مع حلفائها بإطلاق النار على
مئات المدنيين في
جنينة وما حولها يوم 15 يونيو/حزيران.  في واحدة من
أعنف المجازر حتى الآن في
التاريخ الحديث لهذه الإبادة الجماعية التي شوهت
المنطقة السودانية
باستخدام صور الأقمار الصناعية وشهادة شهود العيان
وتحديد الموقع الجغرافي لما
تمكنت منه مقاطع الفيديو القليلة من خلال
انقطاع الاتصالات السلكية واللاسلكية وقطع
أربعة عن العالم
فقدت ثمانية أفراد من عائلتي  في ذلك
اليوم، أثناء هروبه من الجنينة إلى
تشاد، يقول هذا الرجل إنه دفن مئات
الضحايا في تلك القوة منذ أبريل/نيسان،
لكنه في ذلك اليوم لم يتمكن حتى من الوصول إلى
أقاربه المقتولين، وكانت
قوات الدعم السريع مكونة من
قبائل عرب دارفور ومعهم زعيمها
محمد.  حمدان ديجالو والمعروف أيضًا باسم الهيماتي
متورطون في الإبادة الجماعية التي استمرت لسنوات طويلة في
المنطقة ضد التجمعات القبلية الأفريقية،
وليس من
المستغرب إذن أن تأخذ الحرب
بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
للسيطرة على البلاد
منعطفًا أكثر شرًا هنا في تلك القلعة التي
تعكس قوات الدعم السريع.  التكتيكات السابقة التي
أجبرت المدنيين على الفرار، وصل العديد منهم إلى
جانينا
حتى 14 يونيو، عندما تم إعدام
حاكم غرب دارفور الذي شوهد هنا عند اعتقاله
من قبل قوات الدعم السريع، وتنفي قوات الدعم السريع
المسؤولية عن عملية القتل، حيث
حاول المئات الفرار وتعرضوا
للمضايقة والتهديد
حتى الأطفال.  انضم إلينا
عدد قليل من المحظوظين الذين وصلوا إلى تشاد،
وكانوا يقتحمون المنازل ويقتلون
الناس، وكان القناصة في كل مكان
يجلبون معهم قصصًا عن الاستهداف العرقي
على الطريق خارج المدينة، وتم إيقافنا
وتفتيشنا، وأخذوا
هواتفنا، وتم فصل الرجال عن النساء،
لذلك  تمكنا من قتلنا فهربنا لكنهم
أطلقوا النار على بعضنا.
تظهر الأدلة أن الكثير من عمليات القتل
حدثت هنا خارج المستشفى الرئيسي
في جنانا، ثم تم نصب كمين للمدنيين الفارين
مرة أخرى في وادي كاجا.
تظهر صور الأقمار الصناعية النهر الذي عادة ما يكون
ضحلًا بما يكفي لعبور السيارات، وكان به
ماء  كان العشرات يركضون عالياً في ذلك اليوم،
وكافح العشرات في الماء، وأطلق بعضهم
النار أثناء غرقهم، ويقول الناجون إنهم سمعوا إطلاق نار
من جميع الاتجاهات،
ورأيت 17 طفلاً قُتلوا بالرصاص ثم
أُلقوا في الماء، وكان هذا أحد
أكثر المشاهد السريالية التي شاهدتها
رجال الأدلة لدينا.
أصيب أطفال بالرصاص أثناء فرارهم
إلى مستشفى منظمة أطباء بلا حدود في تشاد، وقد
وصل الناجون مصابين بطلقات نارية في
الساقين الخلفية والأرداف، وقال الطبيب الرئيسي لشبكة
CNN، إن جميع الإصابات تتفق مع
إطلاق النار من الظهر، وقد غمر أكثر من 850 شخصًا
المستشفى في أدري في الفترة من
15 إلى 17 يونيو/حزيران.  وفقًا لمنظمة أطباء بلا حدود، أكثر
من أي فترة أخرى منذ
بدء القتال في أبريل/نيسان، يقول جامعو الجثث،
وفقًا لإحصائهم، إن حوالي 1000
شخص قتلوا في يوم 15 يونيو/حزيران،
ودُفنوا في عشرات المقابر الجماعية،
ويقول الناجون إن قوات الدعم السريع تكرر
نفس هذه الأساليب في جميع أنحاء المنطقة.
حتى عندما كان من المفترض أن يحتفلوا في
أعقاب عمليات القتل الجماعي وهذا
الاجتياح للهجمات العرقية المتصاعدة،
أخبرنا الدعم السريع الرسمي للمتحدث الرسمي أنهم
ينفون بشكل قاطع التأكيدات الواردة في
تقاريرنا دون التعليق على
أي من الحوادث المحددة التي وقعت
طرحنا عليهم وأعتقد أنه من
المهم أيضًا الإشارة إلى جيك أنهم
سبق وأن أنكروا نتائج
التحقيقات السابقة قبل أن
تتحولوا وتعلنوا أن
المتورطين في الانتهاكات التي ذكرناها بالتفصيل
ستتم مقاضاتهم ويبدو أن هذا
نمط معهم حقًا